Aventis has always had a key
now I need something more here your
brother is about to declare war we must
stop him
sounds like fun let's do it I'm nobody
but I can't save my home and the people
that I love
mr. Singh
[Music]
in this Trident resides the power of
Atlantis
[Music]
if you seek my power journey beyond the
edge of the world to the hidden sea
in the world hands
it would bring destruction
but in the hands of the truhair
it would unite all our kingdoms and
wealth and below
what we've written it down first I
memorized it didn't you oh yeah
what are you just say something
something Trident the Beast has awakened
the time has come
for Atlantis to rise again
oh is awesome hey everybody its charlie
we got a new Aquaman trailer to break
down we also have a whole bunch of news
about the birds of prey movie they just
cast Ewan McGregor as a really big
Batman villain there's also some news
about the flash movie and some stuff
going on in the background that I'll
include at the end of the video to does
it giveaway for IMAX tickets going on
right now - all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so new footage
first you see an early shot of Meera
coming to the bar where Aquaman hangs
out to try and get him to come back
because of what Oram is doing trying to
rally a war against the surface world
the look on her face is priceless
remember the picture they tweeted out
right as they were starting production
is this photo here this has been out for
so long it's when she first comes back
so Aquaman naturally is like oh hell no
just kind of laughing at her face and
drives off then the scene of him driving
along the bay with that giant tidal wave
coming in him just having this oh crap
look on his face and you could see him
using his power to sort of keep the
water away from the truck that's been
turned over on his side that probably
happens chronologically after this
moment here like after he climbs in his
truck laughing at Meera refusing to
answer the quote-unquote hero's call so
that's sort of the consequence of that
that's probably what shocks him into
action like okay fine I'll go help out
you get a much better shot of arm in his
comic book gear we saw
look at this in the last trailer they
released but it was a little bit fuzzier
you get another shot of him also talking
about the beast rising the thing they're
doing with that is that they might be
combining a couple of comic book ideas
with a couple of Clash of the Titans
ideas because the beast makes it sound
like it's this really huge terrible
thing so they might be combining the
clean of the trench from the comics
which is this monstrous creature that
has this weird connection to all the
creatures of trench they basically want
to turn everything into food eat the
Atlanteans eat the surface world like
just consume all life they might be
combining that idea with a mythical
Kraken from Clash of the Titans like
Poseidon like bangs his Trident and says
release the Kraken and it's this giant
monstrous creature that's going to
destroy everything above land so if King
at lands special Trident is like the
Trident of Poseidon if that's what
they're trying to imply and has these
special godlike powers
it might also have something to do with
control
the beast or subduing it that Oran keeps
talking about the Beast is rising it's
time for Atlantis to rise again too so
if it doesn't come across in the trailer
or wants to kill all humans as well
mostly because of the collateral damage
to Earth's oceans from what happened
during the Man of Steel movie and the
Kryptonian invasion as well as during
the Justice League movie when
Steppenwolf changing the earth also
started to change some of the oceans for
the worse so that wasn't really clear
from Justice League because they cut a
lot of stuff out but when you could see
him using them other boxes to transform
the earth it was also transforming
Earth's oceans ocean master blames the
surface world for all those problems so
he's tried to unite the seven different
kingdoms of Atlantis to kill off the
surface world the whole idea that
Aquaman has to get there first and make
peace with everyone let me know in the
comments though they keep referring to a
beast do you think they're just
combining a couple different comic book
things for a very recognizable unleash
the Kraken type of moment the really big
Batman birds of prey news you guys may
have heard is that you and McGregor was
cast as Black Mask he's gonna be the
main villain of the birds of prey movie
the director also implied that it's
gonna be rated R which would be a first
for DC movies there was that Lobo movie
that was supposed to be rated R I don't
know if that's still gonna get made now
but I'll believe it when I see it
because a lot of times what happens is
they have this really awesome idea and
say okay we'll do it rated R but then
they look at the numbers and they're
like we can earn so much more money if
we make it pg-13 and families can come
to see it
Fox is even doing that with that secret
Deadpool movie is releasing at Christmas
the same day that they're releasing
Aquaman is called the Deadpool before
Christmas
they're Princess Bride and Deadpool too
so that families can go see it so I'll
explain more about that when they start
releasing more promos and trailers
because it'll be a little bit different
from the actual Deadpool 2 that we saw
earlier this year a lot of you were also
asking me about the rumors behind the
Wonder Woman in the flash movie they
delayed the Wonder Woman sequel from
November 2019 to summer 2020 gal gadot
the people behind the movie released
this statement making it sound like they
always wanted or intended for it to be a
summer movie but then a little while
after that another rumor broke that the
real reason for the delay was because
the flash movie was going to be
flashpoint and they were going to use it
to genuinely reboot the DC movie
universe
which is not a new rumor ever since
justice Lee came out people expected
them to do something like that then a
whole bunch of time went by and it
seemed like that wasn't going to happen
right now I do not believe the
flashpoint rumor just because there are
too many unanswered questions about
what's going on with Ben Affleck and
Henry Cavill as Batman and Superman Ben
Affleck has been getting sober and
getting back in Batman shape ahead of
that new Batman solo movie making it
sound like he's just trying to keep that
option open for himself you may have
seen that the CEO of Warner Brothers and
the person that's in charge of all the
DC movies went out to his house to visit
him when he was having all those
problems that almost never happens so
it's a pretty fair bet that they were
trying to convince him to get the help
that he needed and make sure that he
would still be able to be the Batman
character if the opportunity presented
itself we just saw that Henry Cavill
Witcher trailer notice what is missing
on his face he has no facial hair and
Geralt and especially the most recent
game has a pretty prominent beard
they're trying to be more authentic to
the novels and in the novels Geralt
didn't have a beard but it's also a lot
easier for him to shoot cameos and
appear in other DC movies that are
coming up if he doesn't have a crazy
mustache situation going on this time no
more mustache Kade so like there's still
a couple of DC movies that he could
cameo in like the flash movie not
expecting him in the Batman solo movie
the Wonder Woman movie is set during the
past in 1984 so it's a little harder to
justify him showing up during that but
there's still a couple of movies that he
could appear in that are coming up that
we know about let me know what you guys
think about all this in the comments I'm
actually really excited about Ewan
McGregor black mask he's a great actor
and it sounds like the movies gonna be
pretty cool just based on the way
they're pitching it they'll probably
release pictures of all those characters
in their costumes relatively soon so
just leave all your video requests in
the comments below I'll name a new
giveaway winner when I post new DC click
here to watch that henry cavill witcher
trailer and click here for that brand
new flash trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]